with his eye-catching good looks and
magnetic aura it's no surprise why jason
mamoa has charmed so many film and
television viewers he achieved
stupendous silver screen success by
playing aquaman in the blockbuster of
the same name which is the second
highest grossing dc extended universe
movie as of the making of this video
mamoa also gained a claim for his
performance as the charismatic duncan
idaho in the 2021 sci-fi epic dune he
will portray the protector of the deep
for the second time in aquaman and the
lost kingdom which mamoa praised for
being more lighthearted than its darker
dceu counterparts before he was a big
box office draw mamoa was best known for
his role on tv's pre-eminent fantasy
show he appeared as the menacing and
memorable dothraki leader khal drogo
during the first season and one episode
of the second season of game of thrones
in the series premiere winter is coming
drogo enters an arranged marriage with
daenerys targaryen played by amelia
clark the two eventually fall in love
but their relationship is marred in the
beginning by disturbing non-consensual
sex acts while filming these graphic and
disagreeable so-called love scenes momoa
did everything in his power to make his
co-star comfortable since he was so
considerate towards her clark has
publicly praised mamoa for his on-set
behavior game of thrones has been
heralded as one of the greatest shows of
all time but that adulation has not
shielded it from criticism viewers and
critics have called out the hbo series
for its gratuitous sex and nudity emilia
clark appeared in numerous nude scenes
in the first season of game of thrones
often times without any clear
plot-related reason to justify the stunt
since the actress was 23 with only a few
acting credits to her name she was
understandably uneasy not wearing
clothes on set to make matters worse
clark's first intimate scene on game of
thrones involved her character being
sexually assaulted by her husband while
filming the upsetting scene with her
castmate jason amoa he did his best to
make her feel at ease and protected
which is what every young actor deserves
from their scene partners clark told the
armchair expert podcast that momoa took
care of her and was so kind and
considerate toward her she added that he
demanded the crew give her a robe to
cover up and keep warm between takes
clark's account of momoa's onset
behavior proves what a warm-hearted and
thoughtful performer he is it's a
personality trait that shines through
even when he's playing a ruthless
character like the dothraki call jason
mamow's sweet and supportive behavior
towards emilia clarke extended beyond
their intimate scenes the aquaman actor
was incredibly concerned about his got
co-stars health in a beautifully candid
and courageous essay in the new yorker
clark opened up about her potentially
fatal brain aneurysms the same year game
of thrones premiered she experienced a
subarachnoid hemorrhage clark also had
an operation to treat a life-threatening
brain bleed caused by a second aneurysm
two years after the first one ruptured
when entertainment tonight asked mamoa
about clark's health issues he revealed
he had quote kind of been a part of that
whole situation for a very long time he
added that he was trying to find the
right way to come out and help after
clark's health scares mamoa said he was
sad because the world almost lost her
numerous times he also emphasized that
he loves the mother of dragon's
portrayer and that she will do great
things very sad because we almost lost
her numerous times so
i love her to bits and she's here and
she's going to do great things with it
it is clear the former on-screen spouses
share a profound emotional bond they
remain close about a decade after they
met on the got set according to
entertainment weekly mamoa and clark
reunited in august 2021 at david
benioff's birthday party they took
adorable photos together one of which
mamoa posted on instagram with the
caption moon of my life you are
wonderful love you forever
if you or anyone you know has been a
victim of sexual assault help is
available visit the rape abuse and
incest national network website or
contact reigns national helpline at
1-800-656-hope 4673